[Music]
what was once a thick-walled built to
protect one of Hungary's grandest
castles
has been transformed into a lookout with
the most beautiful and panoramic views
of Budapest
[Music]
the fisherman's bastion is a 500 foot
long lookout located on the bank of the
Danube River and is one of the most
visited sites in all of Budapest the
site is only around 100 years old and
was built in celebration of the 1000th
birthday of the Hungarian state the near
Romanesque medieval style architecture
reflects the era of the first Hungarian
King ruled in the year 1000 the bastions
most distinguishing features are the
seven turrets representing the seven
Hungarian tribes who founded the
present-day country in the year 895 the
name fisherman's bastion honors the
guild of fishermen who protected the
castle from being destroyed during the
Middle Ages from enemies the intention
in its construction was to create a
landmark that would showcase Budapest
it's gorgeous views their success is
evident as fisherman's bastion archways
windows and wide Comino stairways
provide a view unlike any other in all
of Budapest
[Music]